ici vous vous trouvez au coeur de
l'innovation dans ce pot vibrant
comprenait un laboratoire où des petits
satellites sont testés on vérifie qu'il
supporte bien les vibrations avant leur
envoi dans l'espace la plateforme
d'intégration et de test de l'ové excuse
située à guyancourt recompte des
équipements scientifiques unique en
france
les moyens que l'on a ici pour la
plupart sont assez innovant certains
n'existent pas forcément dans d'autres
centres
france ou même en europe la machine
derrière moi là
qui est une cuve à vide à la base qui
permet de recréer l'environnement de
l'espace
la fonctionnalité qui vous permet de
recréer l'atmosphère martienne est tout
à fait unique en france et peut-être
même en europe
autre innovation de la plateforme ce mur
d'image immersif il sert à faire de la
modélisation 3d
en ce moment les équipes simule le champ
magnétique de mercure inauguré en juin
la piste comme on l'appelle ici a coûté
6 millions d'euros l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
la région ile-de-france et le cnes ont
participé au financement
désormais il reste à pérenniser
l'activité sont des moyens qui demandent
des financements importants
ne serait ce qu'en termes de maintenance
pour maintenir ses moyens en conditions
opérationnelles
donc notre capacité à offrir du service
nous permet de compenser dans une
certaine partie ces financements
on doit avoir la plateforme
d'intégration et de test est ouvert aux
chercheurs et aux étudiants mais pas
seulement
il souhaite aussi se rapprocher du monde
industriel local
la start-up saint-quentinoise sky one
portal utilisent déjà le mur d'image
immersif